Snarky chat. Snarky chat.
The skulls. The skulls. The skulls. Ethan, we don't care about
the skulls anymore. Okay. Oh, he's Oh my god. No way. No way.
That guy just said that, dude. Take responsibility for your mistakes.
Act like a man. Stop being a whiny. How hard is this? Why don't
you want to attach yourself, Ethan? It
>> Why don't you want to say who sent us this information?
Eton.
Okay. Should we start on
Ethan Klein? Let's see. I'm squashing the beef with Idubbbz H3
show. So, H3 is going to go and not fight with Idubbbz anymore,
apparently. All right. Apparently, this was yesterday. We didn't
get a chance to cover it yesterday.
And there's some funny stuff in here. Okay. This funny stuff.
He ends up going over the Dioro tweet like Nicholas Yoro responding
to him and that'll be funny as well. Okay. There's a lot of coping
there. Let's go. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly.
>> All right. So,
excuse me. As the title thumbnail suggests,
I will be talking about Ian and Ana. There has been an embargo
and it and it and I'll tell you like the oil embargo um of that
hit Japan
pre Pearl Harbor it hurt it is hurting
they they their numbers are anemic
the the members it's down it's basically almost about to go below
like the most loser version of PPP this is like PPP PP
PPP on Xanax. Okay, this is like Xanax PPP.
Hold on. How How would PPP do this? >> They they their
numbers are anemic.
>> Their numbers are anemic.
>> The the members it's down. It's basically almost about
to go below 400. >> THEIR MEMBERSHIP IS BELOW 400,
>> RIGHT? The viewership is in the what two
NOBODY WATCHES THEM,
YOU KNOW? LIKE, why don't put some energy in, man? Put some energy
and effort in, dude. >> Very different show with Nate on
the soundboard. I got to be >> I do like I'm watching a
Tik Tok.
>> I like, by the way, I can't even match it now, man.
>> Quit out of embarrassment.
She started streaming and she's like, "Yeah, I'm building a fan
base." I'm like, "Uh, Ian, this is the best. I'm so good at this."
to all of a sudden flash forward. She can't even hold 80 live
viewers. And now she's like, "Actually, I'm too busy for this.
You're busy. You don't have a job. You don't have kids. You're
not busy. You're a loser. Excuse me." >> Dude, this is
so sad, man. This is so
>> How the are you going to tell me? >> This is why
we have to squash beefs with like random people. Okay. You can't
you can't ever become Ethan Klein. You just got to like let stuff
go. If you carry stuff for so long, it just starts to corrode
your soul,
right? You just got to let it go. You just got to
let it go. It's gone. We don't care anymore. It's fine. I mean,
you're busy if you don't even have a job or kids. You should
How?
Busy doing what exactly? Serving an uncut bagel on a paper plate.
>> How exactly are you spending your time? But anyway,
>> good one, Ethan. >> I'm a big fan if you can't
tell.
But at any rate, I am breaking the
but it's for one last time.
Um, and I I
this is it. Like, I'm out.
you know, I broke the embargo recently because uh Ian issued
an apology to me and my family
>> for platforming the um let's say
the silly light-hearted joke. >> Oh my god, dude. This
is Yeah. Yeah. I'm just going to play it now. We can just watch
it now.
>> Yeah. This is
>> This is unironically posted, I believe, to the H3H3
subreddit. I thought it was photoshopped or I thought it was
edited somehow. I thought it was AI. I didn't want to believe
that it existed. To be honest, this is like I watch this and
I'm like, "Dude, let the tech billionaires win. Let's see what
they can do with humanity." We We did fail. We need transhumanism.
Let the tech billionaires win. Make us eat bugs. Actually, humanity
was a mistake. >> Yeah. Hold down a job.
>> Listen to this. The dude is unemployed.
>> He's ugly. I value you.
>> He can't eat the dude. >> Never been able to work.
>> On the bills.
>> You're better off with it. You're honestly better off
alone. But guess what? A better man is just around the >> Oh
my god. >> This can't be real. I do believe it's real.
I I
dude, I do believe it's real. People are saying it's real. I'm
being I'm being informed it's real. video activates some deep-seated
Mongolian conquest instinct within my stomach. Jesus Christ,
Kilo. Jesus Christ, Kilo.
Caption says, "Everything I have to
But and then I saw people being like, "Okay, honestly,
this is development. Ian is is actually
maybe he's um he's come along. Maybe he's actually developing
as a character." But I was the only one that knew. No, it happened
like one day after we sent them a cease and desist, they stopped
talking about us,
>> right? So, I know why they stopped and I know we have
a really good case in Canada and their lawyer told them that,
right? And so,
essentially that's what it is. But uh so Ian and Ana reacted
to
my uh response to them
which was um basically just saying that I sent them a cease and
assist. >> We got a cease and desist.
And obviously that you know I I was being um
genuine uh in my apology cuz I I was reflecting. >> Yeah.
Yeah. He was being genuine. It just so happened to coincide
with the immediately receiving a cease and assist. Not the fact
that you like spend your whole day
in with and in and supporting and calling shouting out a community
whose logo
is a skull with a CPS written across it.
what's that reference, guys? Who's he Who could he possibly Who
could he possibly be talking about? Who would do that? Who could
do that? Who would do such a thing? A skull with CPS written
on it. Who would do such a thing? That's crazy. Okay, that's
totally crazy. >> You thought that was funny and awesome
and cool, right? Until the moment you got a cease and assist.
You had a you you had a moment of clarity and then you got a
cease and assist right afterwards and and then you really meant
it.
>> Cool. And um I think it was out of out of line for my
own personal is Idubbbz in the Jtock Kiwi Farms Pisco Hassan
Cabal now. Yes, that is what Ethan is saying. Yes, that is what
he's saying.
>> I guess goals in life and like how I wants to be, >> Um
and I think ultimately even after my apology, he still doesn't
seem to be to think that it's real or genuine. >> Yeah.
Why? Why? Uh yeah, you're right,
Why I should I should take it as the way it was meant to be.
Just completely sincere.
Like if he, you know, unironically,
if he had issued this type of apology like
I don't know, months ago, I would have thought it was sincere.
But to do it like right after you get a cease and desist, how
can I like I'm I'm not even being this to be like snarky. I'm
being like, how am I actually supposed to think it's sincere?
If I thought it was sincere, I would like, you know, my I would
have a my heart would soften. You know, I I'm the first person
to let a grudge go when I'm apologized. All you have to say is
I'm funny. Right, Dan? You know that
>> he's not actually joking about that. That That is true.
>> I'm so quick to forgive. >> He's quick to anger,
but quick to >> To a fault, I would say even >> huge
fault. Probably one of the biggest biggest I've ever seen on
any person.
>> See Dan. Yeah, Dan. >> Dude, is that That's like
the Yeah, that's the show now is they like subtly try to just
rain Ethan in. Try to keep it on the rails. Can we just keep
this on the rails, man? We got another year and a half of of
milking these morons in our audience dry before this runs out.
Could you just keep us on track? I need this job for at least
another year and a half. Okay. >> Understands me and he
should after all these years. Yeah. >> Listen, I don't
I don't watch the podcast. In fact, it gives me an aneurysm and
it like distresses me greatly to watch it. So, I I only hear
it through the >> You just catch clips of it on your snark
subreddit. Those ones don't upset you. >> Yeah. I only
like watching the worst clips that are upsetting. >> Mhm.
The ones that are curated explicitly to upset me. Those ones
are terrible. But I I'm on that subreddit all day every day.
And I'm not even being like hyperbolic.
You rolled out this Scorch Legume character
for the express purpose of browsing Snark, >> which is
a shame that he tied that branding to this because now he can't
continue the character. And it was >> that he tied that
to sorry he
just to browse snark like you do to do segments on them like
they weren't doing before you started on them like it's just
such a it's such a comedy of errors like there's no reason he
should have ever gone after Idubbbz and anise in the first place.
He just had no reason to right. I think he did it purely because
they're kind of cringe and he just wanted a good enemy to have.
I don't really think there was any reason to go after them.
They were just being silent. They're just sitting in their corner.
I understand that if you think they're your friends, it feels
wrong for them to sit in the corner over there, okay, and not
do anything. But it's just so It's so weird, man. It's so weird
now. It >> was so It was so funny that it's just such a
shame,
>> you know?
It it it is right. >> Did Dan just imply that was so funny?
>> There's like a
snarky chat. Snarky chat.
bro, this is crazy. The shout outs go hard, man.
This is totally wild. I don't know why
Why do they Man, I am Am I crazy? They just make us seem so cool.
They make us seem like terrorists and then like these guys are
unemployed. These guys are so so mean and unemployed and evil.
Like, dude, can you not [__] on somebody and hold
down a job? I can. I've done it. I participate in these communities
online. I was in something of a snark community when I was employed
full-time making
Well, to the six figures, okay? I was in a smart community.
It was DG, by the way. But I was in a Stark community. All right.
It's very easy to be in a Stark community that watches streams
a lot and comments on them and sh on people. It's very easy to
do that and be employed at the same time.
these like yeah just total lack of ambition total lack of drive
people they have no passion you're passionate about something
you make time for it all right we're passionate about this
chatter of this like secret discord
of like crazy Twitter uh Reddit political snarkers
like these high level >> crazy Reddit Twitter political
snarkers and by the way he's going to talk about I think the
grill pill people is who talking about, right?
I don't I like unless somebody's in there on an alt and I'm unaware
of it.
It's I don't think a single one of those grill pill Jake Chinatown
people is in there. He's that's who's going to blame >> reply
guys.
It's all starting to come out. I don't >> the highle reply
guys. >> Well, you know, like the the Jake Chinatowns and
all these characters. >> Ah, yeah. Yeah. >> The bad.
>> I'm just I'm I'm listen I'm distancing from Jake Chinatown.
Not on any moral grounds. on like I don't even know what his
Twitter's about to be honest with you. I know he's like a pro-Hassan
like anti-
what's a Twitter community. I know he like posts he's like a
leftyish or whatever, right? But I don't know that much about
him. I'm only distancing cuz I do not want Flesh Simulator to
dox me. Okay, Flesh Simulator, stop. Stop. I'm not I'm not involved.
Okay,
that's I know that they've got beef with the Flesh Simulator
guy. Okay, that's what I know.
It's all starting to come out. The high level reply guys. >> Well,
you know, like the the Jake Chinatowns and all these characters.
>> Yeah. Yeah. >> The bad empanadas and you know
all these regular who say the worst possible things and then
they're re uh retweeted by Hassan like once or twice a month
to feed the machine. This is the whole thing. This is how Hassan
This is the insane coordination. When Hassan sees somebody on
somebody he doesn't like and retweets it. That's insane coordination,
guys. That's insane coordination. It couldn't be that we're just
total scum. It couldn't be that we're just like some of the worst
human beings going on the entirety of YouTube. It couldn't be
that. It just has to be that Hassan is coordinating all of it.
It couldn't be us. It couldn't be me and my total psychopathy
towards all these people. It It has to be them. It has to be
Hassan. The only The only way people don't like me is Hassan.
No, Ethan. We just watch you. We just see you. We just see you.
We don't like
Ed Hassan likes something funny. Yeah. Yeah. It's just sad, man.
This is goofy.
>> So, somebody leaked is has somehow got this entire log
over the past year and a half
and I haven't seen the messages, but I have seen the name and
look. >> So, why would he say that? Oh, someone got this.
Someone got this, guys. I don't know who, but like someone got
it. Like, someone somewhere got it.
Why don't you Hey, Ethan, why don't you want to say
who's telling you about this? Why don't you want to say
who did get the leak? Why don't you want to attach yourself?
Ethan. Itan. Hey, why don't you want to say who sent us this
information? Anon,
can anybody tell me? Oh, cuz it's destiny. And you want to act
like you aren't this dude's.
Wow. Wow. Wow.
And I haven't seen the messages, but I have seen the name and
logo for this snark community. And I mean, they wear it like
a badge of honor, right? That CPS came to my house, that human
skulls were sent to my house. Two of them. And I mean, the these
are the groups of people you've spent the last year aligning
with. Ah, the skulls. The skulls. The skulls. Ethan, we don't
care about the skulls anymore, okay?
We joke about the skulls now. We don't care about the skulls.
You got You got like a total You got like a year and a half of
psychopathy off of the skulls. No more. We're done with the skulls
now. Okay. Yeah. Like your full year and a half in year and a
half. Well, hold on. Full year. Full year of psychopathy. We
don't care about the skulls anymore, man. We're done. It's We're
good. We don't need any more of that.
And you know, listen,
I just I just it's hard for me to feel bad. It is.
It is >> right. Fine. I have to, you know, to use a little
bit of a therapy term. I have to protect my peace. So, I don't
know what any details are, but I think in summary, it look >> take
a vow of celibacy and go to a monastery. I don't know what to
tell you. So, there's no peace to be had
>> I just need to protect you my peace. >> You I
just need to protect like my peace. Okay.
>> You sacrificed that piece to the altar of clout when
you made that content cop about me,
>> How long ago was that again now? >> Over a year.
>> It was like around Was it around time last year? >> About
a year. >> I don't I don't want to be that guy.
I don't want to be the guy that's suing people that's like, you
know. >> Yes, you do. You want to be the guy that's loved,
but nothing about how you act makes you loved. So, you're doing
the next best thing. What do you mean? I don't want to be I just
want everybody to love me, but I'll take suing them into loving
me if that's if that fails.
Okay. Okay. >> Obsessively just on you no matter how minute
and ridiculous it is forever all the time.
>> Isn't that your brand kind of >> dude? What?
Oh, he's Oh my god. No way.
No way. That guy just said that, dude. Dude, what?
Wow. Wow. Dude, I got to watch it again. Back further. Back.
>> You sacrificed that piece to the altar of clout when
you made that content cop about me, right? >> How long
ago was that again now? Over a >> Dude, dude, dude, dude,
dude. This is like This is why you got to let stuff go, man.
All your friends just be like, "Dude, that was so long ago, man."
Are you seriously still on about this? How long ago was that?
It was a year ago. Oh, it was over a year ago. Oh, and you're
still ass pained about it? Yeah. Okay. All right. Whatever you
say, >> It was like around Was it around time last year?
>> About a year. >> I don't I don't want to be that
guy.
>> I don't want to be the guy that's suing people that's
like, >> you know, obsessively just on you no matter how
minute and ridiculous it is forever all the time.
>> Isn't that your brand? >> About that.
>> I don't want to be that guy though, you know? And but
ultimately
>> dude that just rolls off him too. Oh no. He was stands
broken for like a millisecond. He's just like I don't want to
be that guy. No, I don't want I don't want that. >> When
you do what you did when you put out that video when I was live
when you when you
encouraged and applauded the CPS visits you justified.
>> Didn't encourage and applaud the CPS visits. Are you
Why are you so insanely
stealth victimizing?
Like what? What the? Show me. Someone show me. Someone show me
anywhere.
What the What are we even talking about, man? What are we talking
about, dude? >> Blaine, I know people who watch the show
understand the we've been dealing with since all this stuff,
but it's hard to understand. Like,
>> this is a group of 50 people that have spent all day
and night, 24 hours a day
dedicated to ruining mine and many other people few other people's
lives. >> No. Nope. I understand that accountability might
look that way to somebody who's led a really life and made millions
of dollars doing it, but no. Nobody wants to ruin your life.
You could ride off into the literally just stop abusing people.
Literally, just stop being a total piece of just stop right now.
You escape everything. You don't even have to do anything, dude.
You are independently wealthy. You don't have to BE HERE. YOU
CAN'T OPT in to being a total You can't be a total piece of and
opt into public commentary and then go, "These guys are really
mean. These guys are really, really mean. Shut
So, it's so stupid, man. >> But this is like specifically
like, "Yeah, the clients." And you've encouraged them. >> You're
so mean to me. >> You've you've endorsed them, man. You've
called them great people. You've sent people there.
And right up until the day before you got that cease and desist,
you were applauding them, right? And just suddenly had a change
of heart. So I apologize for not taking your apology sincerely.
I do.
You know, I've had little reason to. >> Is your apology
sincere or is this an insincere apology to
>> dude? It's rough. I have a little I have a little bit
of empathy for Ethan Klein because he's like
listen he's got people around him who want to retain his human
who want him to retain his humanity.
I get it. He wants to be like a demon but they're like no. Hey
Ethan, you should be nice. >> Sorry. I'm sorry. I guess
in a I'm sorry that I don't believe it. I don't know if that's
I don't know what that means. I wish I could believe it was sincere.
>> Dan does see what's going on. Dan Dan sees everything.
that would actually make me feel
like um like good like that. >> I dude, can we be that
far away from Dan leaving the show? I feel like Dan is he's very
obviously understanding like he gets it. He sees what's going
on. Also, it's not as bad. It's not as bad. But he he sees what's
going on and how far away could we possibly be from from him
possibly leaving or something? I don't know. >> Was you
know some peace to be had? >> Too well paid maybe.
But how can I see it as sincere given the circumstance?
You know,
>> looks like he he's interested, Ethan, in pursuing a
lawsuit here in Canada. Um, I ultimately am just like not interested
in like playing that game. >> Yeah, that's funny.
Of course you're not.
He's like, I don't want to get sued, so I'm not going to. But
that's not how it works. Of course, >> dude. It's so cowardly
to like have the the idea of a lawsuit hanging over these people's
heads and you're like just on them just like, "Well, I guess
you guys you guys like reacted to something I said." And you
know what?
Not smart with a lawsuit. I'm going to sue you. I'm I'm ready
to sue you, dude. Even if he hasn't sued them, even if he's like
not serious about it, the the idea of it now is a cudgel in and
of itself. And he's just a total piece of [__] He's
just total scum for doing this. Well, I'm going to talk about
you and if you talk back, I'm going to sue
>> I, you know, and I don't want to sue you, right? I I
don't want to do all this. But >> Yes, you do. Yes, you
do. Yes, you do. This is not outside of your control. You are
an adult. Stop acting like such a whiny.
You are a man. Act like a man. How difficult is it?
You say the things that you say and you bring consequences. You
don't like Oh my god. I I When you talk about your family's health
situation on a stream, you are not protecting your family. That
is not what a a protector does. Act like a man, Ethan Klein.
Take responsibility for your mistakes. Act like a man. Stop being
a whiny. How hard is this?
>> At the end of the day, I have made a commitment and
I am
the ultimate hater. And that's
not even an opinion. >> No man, let me tell you, the ultimate
haters are in that are in that CPS Skull Discord, okay? That's
where the ultimate haters are. You don't know, bro. You are doing
this cuz you're rich and it cost you nothing. Could you imagine
the kind of people who want to do the same [__] Who
want to like go and follow somebody all the time, follow all
of their content, watch every hour of their stream?
They're just doing it for the love of the [__] game.
Can you imagine Ethan Klein? Can you imagine people just doing
it for the love of the game? They're not They're not rich. They
don't pay somebody else to look up the timestamps. They watch.
They search, right? They they do transcript searches. They do
all these things just just because they think you're a bad person
and somebody should watch that clip of you being a bad person
and laugh at you. >> But I do truly believe that do when
Dr. Mike gave Ian brain damage, that's when he became anti-semitic.
>> Oh, it's all anti-semitism.
It's all anti-semitism in Hassan, guys.
>> I really truly do believe that. But the last thing this
guy needs, man, is more sand in his gears. You know, please don't
fight. >> Maybe it'll fix things, you know? It's like when
you hit a controller, eventually it works. I have found that
to occasionally be helpful >> to smack a computer or something.
It does fix it sometimes. >> It could knock the anti-semitism
out of >> Why? Why do this? Why go live and just do this
like weird neuroticism calling this guy anti-semitic? What has
he said or done that's anti-semitic?
Like anything
at all.
The sword is is the sword. We're going to do the sword. It was
I guess it's just the sword, guys. >> Who would have to
hit him in the head to do that? I don't know. Look it up. Google
it.
>> As much as I don't like Ian, I don't want to see him
like in a even worse state, right? Nobody deserves that. I mean,
listen, if you do another fight, who's to say? Why are you trying
to cope?
Trying to destroy his life. Don't cope. This is the thing. This
is the most despicable duplicitous in my
If you want to go demon time, you want to be that guy. you want
to be the guy who destroys these people, then be that guy, but
actually do it. Don't do this halfway cope of like, um, well,
like, I actually just don't want to see them in a worse place,
but I'm going to sue them for all they're worth, and I just want
them to be happy, maybe, but I also am hinting at sending somebody
to beat them up. And like, just dude, go one way or the other.
Like, you're not
like you're already doing the worst thing. If you were like saying,
"Okay, you you walk up to a threshold and you want to walk back
from it." I understand, but you're already doing the worst thing.
You are already threatening to sue him. You're already threatening
to ruin his life to to take his financial security away.
You understand that? Like anything you could say is less bad
than that? Like literally, you could go live and you could leak
like you could leak some terrible childhood trauma in this guy
and that would be less bad than trying to destroy his financial
security. You're already doing the worst thing. And then you're
like, "Well, I don't want to joke about like somebody hitting
him." No, joke about somebody hitting him. Don't sue him.
That's actually long-term life ruining.
And it's only it's only like total psychopaths like this in the
internet who have enough money to sue all the people they want
that would ever think this way. Everybody else has skin in the
game. They've got stake, right? They've got a stake in and they
don't want to lose it. It's It's so psychotic, man. It's just
embarrassing. >> I need to pull the plug. I mean, >> yes.
Yes. Suing Idubbbz is actually worse than a CPS call. I totally
agree with that. A CPS call is really bad. Would never endorse
it. A CP a CPS call is way over the line for online.
Suing him over a over a joke that he leaves up on stream, even
if it's defamatory.
It's I'm sorry that is worse. You are trying to destroy this
guy's life. You
a CPS call is some plausible good reason to do it. You're just
crashing out on Idubbbz cuz he called you a [__]
gonna be in. You think she's not gonna pull the plug if you're
in a close to vegetative state? >> She's pulling the plug.
>> Exactly. You think she's not pulling that plug? >> So
many options there. She's like, >> you might even you might
even just be in a coma and they'll be like, there's a good chance
he'll be back in a week.
>> She's like, pull the plug. I I hate to see him like
this. It's >> like a million-dollar baby.
>> That's sad movie. That's a spoiler, dude. Come on. >> Sorry.
Button it. >> It is so crazy. >> Like, you know what
I mean?
>> uh, it's so up just the whole idea of like I'm gonna
these guys, they've got like a house there. They've got a what
was the joke about like we we're going to take his house in Portland
or
It's just so psycho. It's just totally >> I wouldn't pull
the plug. I wouldn't. That's why it's such a shame that you threw
our friendship away. I would have paid to keep you on life support
even when the the waves in your brain had ceased to flow.
But there was a there's still a murmur in your heart. A beat,
a pulse. Would have kept it alive. Not her. In fact, do we >> I
think he'd be locked to a 24-hour stream from his hospital bed
with TTS in a donation goal playing the content cop theme every
$100.
>> Even know when she got >> I don't know. Do I cope
about Nicholas ever having been funny? Cuz that I don't know
what that's supposed to be. But okay. Insurance. >> Did
she leap the mole? Little fisherman fan. Okay. People saying
Lee the Mole or something about AB tapes. You you guys aren't
going to have any sort of effect on me. All right. No effect.
>> I think he's talking about this this leaked Discord.
Snark Discord. I don't know what else cuz they say >> is
he the mole? There was a mole in >> I don't think so. It's
just because he he said a while ago
in the office. >> Oh, Ethan.
Oh, you just you're so obsess he's so obsessed with it already.
Just the idea.
Oh, buddy.
Oh, no.
He's so obsessed with the idea of this Discord already.
No, there's a literal mole in their house. There's a literal
mole in their house. Oh,
it's all about the Discord. Idups is in the Discord and a song's
in the Discord. Pass messages to the Discord. I see it all. I
see it all.
We're going to get them. We're going to get them. Nobody can
possibly dislike me this much. Nobody can possibly It's all because
Hassan and items are telling them to. And I can prove it. I'll
prove it to you guys. You guys hear me? I'll prove it. I'll be
vindicated. I'll be vindicated in the end. I can prove it. And
you know I can prove it. And that's why you're scared. And that's
why you're telling me to move on. That's why you're telling me
to move on with my life that I'm being obsessed. But you're actually
just trying to trick me because all of you really want you really
want Adams to get away with this. You want Hassan to get away
with it? Cuz Dan, you used to like Hassan. Remember when we did
leftovers, Dan? And you liked Hassan? You laughed at his jokes,
but you can't laugh at my jokes now, Dad. Really? Really? Really?
Sorry, I got a little too into the character listening. >> They
were saying leak to a pig. >> Jesus Christ. >> Yeah.
You know how I know that that he doesn't have a mole? Not that
I need any anything at all. Seemed pretty surprised when he got
that cease and assist. Everybody in this office knew exactly
what I was doing. Every single one of them. Every one of them.
>> So, your mole dropped the ball on that one, buddy.
>> The most growth.
M growth possibilities are an interesting one. That might actually
be a battle I would lose.
>> See, he just said he has small.
>> And Nissa already said that.
>> Very, very powerful. Very mighty powerful
in the short period of time. I'm not talking about the the growth
I've had over the past 10 years because that is colossal.
Uh I mean I'm being extremely serious when I say those things.
It's not because I do realize a lot of this is unfortunately
I don't think it should be content. I don't think these things
should be broadcasted on the internet, especially if you're serious
about it. Um, what
>> I mean this is about this is about my
>> No, it's not. Oh, dude. Come on, man.
>> Don't make it about your Don't use your kids, bro. And
you you say Hassan uses kids as a shield. Holy, man.
Are you serious?
This is about my kids. This is about my kid. Dude, your kids
don't know anything about this.
And you are, by the way, if you thought that people with nothing
to lose, total losers on the internet who were calling in anonymous
to your house, if you thought that you're going to scare them
away by doxing some people or attacking some people, you thought
any of that was going to happen, that's you're going to get the
opposite. As every single person on the internet has found out
every single time, you can't threaten people away from you on
the internet about like this. You you just can't do it. You can
identify other targets and make them hurt for covering it if
you want.
I you can do that. You're going to you're going to 10x your hate
every single time you do it. So, if you want to if you want to
go down that trail and you want to totally destroy yourself,
feel free to. The the true path to happiness for your kids is
to stop getting so invested in these fights. Just do your show.
Stay away from Enan and Issa. Stay away from your old friend
group. Move on with your life and be happy. That's how you could
be. That's what would be good for you and your kids. any other
any other choice, any other course of action is going to continuously
get you into drama, continuously get you into fights, and you're
basically putting winning an internet beef with Idubbbz, Casey,
Tron, Froggen, Denims above the well-being of everyone around
you. That's what you're trying to do. Yeah. I mean, that's what
he's trying to do. It's sad. And I'm not going to tell you you
can't. You can do that. It's more content for everybody on the
internet. I guess kind of, but >> people forget. But when
this whole thing started, when CPS came to my house, came on
the show the same day. >> You were planning to sue these
people before CPS came to your house, you lying duplicitous
worm.
>> Day and I told everybody the rules of enga engagement
have changed. The line has moved. The barriers are gone. That
was a year ago. It's taken me time, right, to to for all my plans
to culminate and stuff.
But I meant that these people went after my children and and
maybe you didn't make the call, Ian, but you [__]
love the people that did
>> So you basically know he's not responsible for the call.
He doesn't love those people. Nobody loves those people. That
call, by the way, basically everybody who doesn't like Ethan
and talks about him on the internet will agree that that calls
beyond the pale. You should not make that call, right? They're
they basically all be like, "Yeah, it's probably a little too
far." There are some people, but it's probably too far.
But here's the thing. It's like
it's over the line. But there is some person there are some there's
some group of people who are not crazy who could make that call
based on the you said.
And so while I would bet on a crazy person having done it who's
probably like an insane person who hates you, like somebody who
spends a ton of time on the internet or something, right? I would
bet on that. It's not for sure. And you put your family at risk
with the way you talked and you'll never take responsibility
for it. problem saying like maybe it was needed. I don't know.
Your fans seemed worried when nobody was worried and he shows
comments kaka house. Clearly they're >> Klein poo poo house.
So
this is this is this is and has always been about my
>> Oh that's a total lie. >> You forgot because it's
been so long, right? You think >> you're actually such
a disgusting
fantastic [__] Dude, are you serious? This has always
been about my children. It's about your ego. You're just a piece
of It's always been about your ego. It was never about what's
best for your kids. You're There's a real chance your kids know
don't remember this. You know what's going to You know what's
going to crystallize that into a memory? You constantly yapping
about it to everybody. You constantly spiraling in your grievance
about it.
There's a chance your kids could have moved on from this and
never thought about it again. You are crystallizing it for them
because you are an egotistical, whiny.
And again, I will I'll do the throat
Nobody should have done that. Obviously, touching the poop is
bad. If somebody did that, hypothetically, if somebody did that,
which I would bet on that being the most probable explanation,
that's really, really bad. I never would want anybody in my audience
to do something like that. I wouldn't want anyone in any adjacent
audience to do something like that. But holy, man, it's you could
have moved on and you've made it your entire personality for
the past year.
It's the only thing you talk about, man.
>> A silly game for content or something. It's It's not
for me. I haven't
>> You think I forgot that CPS came to my house and interviewed
my children?
>> Everybody else forgets, bro. >> I I have not forgotten.
>> Like, if I'm being overly charitable to him, I can see
thinking your family's being attached, causing you to spazz and
do the wrong thing, but then to sustain the wrong thing and double
and triple and quadruple down on it. Yeah, exactly. Like, if
he just freaked out and filed those lawsuits and then been like,
"You know what? That would have been, man, I could have been
an Ethan Klein fan if he if he'd like filed those lawsuits and
gone, "Oh, you know what? This is too much. I got a little too
into this. I'm actually back it off. I'm going to move on. I'm
going to try to do better
right? I could I could totally do that." But I have >> I
could be I could be an Ethan Klein fan if he had done that. If
he just identified pretty quickly that, hey, this was a mistake.
I think the Rubicon is the Casey Trot apology where he just like
transparently didn't give a about the law or his copyright. He
just wanted to humiliate Casey Tron. He just wanted to like extract
clout from that situation. As soon as that became clear, it wasn't
about punishing her. By the way, if it was about your kids, if
it was about creating like this this idea that you were with
and it was about your kids and you need to [__] you
need to some people up to show you couldn't be attacked, you
would have bankrupted Caseyron. That's just facts, buddy. But
it wasn't about that. You wanted
It was actually showing I will destroy you if you come after
my kids. You would have taken that opportunity and bankrupted
her, but you didn't cuz you wanted to. You didn't want to seem
like a piece of [__] to everybody around you. This
is you waffling again. You're not that guy. And you'll never
be happy trying to pretend that you are that guy. You're like
a nerdy guy. You're not like this this gigachad in high school
who didn't get stuffed in lockers. You're the nerdy kid who got
stuffed in lockers and became artistic and then eventually made
a YouTube channel. All right. Stop trying to like become somebody
you're not. You're not You're spiritually just not that guy,
man. It's just it's rough to watch cuz he's he has he has everything
he needs to be happy in the world and he won't just walk away
and take it and have it and just be happy. It's so sad, man.
>> And just like I promised, right? Just like I promised
then. I'm literally just following through in my promises that
I made back then. It's all >> Well, I'm totally safe then
cuz when that happened, I was totally on Ethan Klein's side.
I was like, "Oh, this is disgusting. Oh, this is horrible. Oh,
it's up that they Dude, that's like worse than a swatting. It's
worse than a swatting this the calling CPS. That's worse than
a swatting. Like I was totally on his side. He's burned all goodwill
with me in the past year, man. I had some goodwill left. I've
got nothing left now. All I'm doing. >> I think the whole
thing is extremely silly. Uh so I would be fine. >> And
also, listen, if you didn't want to get sued or deal with this,
don't put a statement on your screen that says I my children.
I mean, that's not rocket science, is it? It's pretty basic
>> Wouldn't basic decency to be like to do something to
the guy who's calling you a
>> It's not. >> If uh it not >> or you try
to is the lesson there for your kids that when they go back and
watch your content that this guy stepped back to you, you got
slapped and so you let him say you your kids. Is that the lesson
you're you're leaving in history now? You got slapped by Destiny
and then you walked away and he knew he you so he started talking
about how you're a your kids. I would never say that about you
but Destiny did and you totally took it because you are a [__]
You are his
not you know with just uh what do you call that? What do they
call it? I think I don't think there's an official name for it.
Financial torture. I think it's it's an attempt of doing a financial
torture in my opinion. In my opinion >> it's called accountability.
Okay. When people push you and repeatedly push you and do things
and you respond, you try to use your words to respond, makes
it worse. They take it out of context. They push, they push,
they push, they make it worse. They send CPS. They send skulls.
That's it. They make these silly [__] snark groups.
>> Dude, um, just I do want to
They make these stupid snark groups. I liked Ethan Klein.
I was fine with Ethan
I was on his side when the CPS call was made and he burned all
goodwill with me. So if you're if this is about your kids, Ethan,
and anybody who is it's just about your kids and CPS, know that
back then I was on your side and your actions since then have
turned me entirely against you. I think you were a totally you're
a massively harmful, total piece of you're a dirt bag and you
need to you need to honestly be held accountable too, right?
Just like you're trying to hold items accountable, you're you
need to be held accountable, too. Okay. >> Why should denims
be allowed to just steal my content wantingly?
This is accountability.
This is not financial torture. This is the system. I'm using
the system in the only way that I can. I'm sorry that the system
is up and that you don't like the results, the ramifications
for your actions, but this is not
this is not torture. This is this is consequences of your guys'
direct action. Uh-huh. I didn't have to. >> Why does he
even Why would you even argue that those would be mutually exclusive?
They're just obviously not mutually exclusive at all. It's just
weird to even pretend that you think >> Like, it's just
an obvious lie. >> Any of you guys. And frankly, I would
love to not be in any lawsuits, right?
>> You know, you have the power not to do that, right?
>> Um, so listen, I'm not going to say if I'm suing him
or not. I'm going to deal with all this stuff. >> Yeah,
we we couldn't guess. We couldn't say. No, I can't say if I'm
suing him or not, guys. No, you know what? No. No, no, no, no,
no. >> Behind the scenes and I I'm out. I'm done talking
about them. I wish them all the best. I mean, >> it's so
sad that like it's so transparently about his ego. Again, he
makes the argument that he has to do all of these things because
these people went after his kids. But then when he gets a chance
to actually hurt one of these people, these people that he claims
went after his kids, he totally takes a knee and lets them apologize.
Now, I think that's the better outcome for Casey Tron. But if
it was really not about his ego, if it wasn't about internet
beefs and petty shallow petty shallow like jokes that people
told that hurt his ego, if it was about really just his kids
and protecting his kids and setting a precedent, he would have
bankrupted Caseyron, right?
He would have he would have stood on business here and said,
"Yes, I am suing Idubbbz because it's about my kids." But instead,
because Nicholas Doro says, "No, no, no, no, don't do that, Ethan.
You can't do that." Now he's like, "Oh, I can't say if I'm suing
him now. I can't even say. No, I can't even say.
It's never been about your kids. It's just about your ego. Stop.
Come on, man. >> In a sense, in like the proverbial
>> Listen, sometimes the best path forward take includes
steps backwards.
And me wishing them the best is maybe them doing the right thing
behind the scenes.
>> In a real job, >> they make a hell of a lot more
money. Yeah. But I'm I'm out. And uh good luck to them and all
that. and uh everything I do is just going to be uh I by the
way I never even planned to really even talk about the lawsuit
with them or the cease and assist. I only brought it up because
he started like dancing around like he was some paragon of principles
and stuff and I was like no you're not. Also I just want to give
a shout out to my friend the pope Nicholas Dioro who
he's having a hard time uh rationalizing my decision and that's
fine.
Listen, I like Nick. He's the pope. You can't question the pope.
Don't make me Don't make me blow that gray smoke. I'm just kidding.
I was just I was just trying to play the analogy.
Excuse me. He's having a hard time uh rationalizing my decision.
And that's fine. >> Mr. Nicholas Dioro can't rationalize
Ethan Clyde's decision-m. >> Listen, I like Nick. Don't
make me don't make me blow that gray smoke. I'm just kidding.
I was just I was trying to play the analogy.
Excuse me. No, I completely don't mind him thinking this is stupid
or petty or that he disagrees, but he says again can't for the
life of me fathom why it would be a flex. This he said it's just
two poor losers in Canada over them showing a comment completely
different person said without pursuing destiny
um I've seen a few people that I like echoing this sentiment.
So that's why I thought I'll just respond to it and
with love, right? Just to to to explain myself. I mean, I I've
explained like the technical aspect of it that one, Destiny lives
in America. Two, he he
soon after stated he doesn't believe it. Right? So those are
two disqualifying facts. But
I it's like I said, I said this a year ago or plus when it started.
I'm just following through on my promises, man. It's not a flex.
I'm not doing it to flex. I'm not doing it to be >> You've
been doing it to flex the whole >> Cool. I'm not doing
it. >> Stop making it about
good. Makes me look good or cool. I probably makes me look unhinged,
right? To the general public. I probably look like a crazy person
that's suing everybody. And I >> You have looked like a
crazy person that's suing everybody since you started suing people.
Yeah, >> I understand that. I don't want to be that guy.
>> You are that guy. You do want to be that guy. If you
understand that and you do it anyway, then you want to be that
guy,
>> I don't want to be that guy for this show. I don't want
to be that guy for this person, for people that love me. I don't
want to be wrapped up in this stuff. But
listen, people came after my >> I understand perfectly
that everybody sees me as a crazy person suing
And I don't want to be that guy, but I'm going to keep suing
people. Yeah, you're just there's something broken here. You
do want to be that guy. children and I said the rules changed
and they did change and they haven't gone back to how they used
to be just because it's been a year just because people forgot
about it or people
the impact of it is lessened on them cuz it's not lessened on
me and Ela it's not lessened on me and my wife we live in the
same house same children so
um that
yeah Ian and Nissa they've met my children I mean it's personal
these people have into my house. They they've met my children.
And then for them to claim
on a huge platform that it's good that CPS came to investigate
the tip the that my children were eating dog [__]
off the floor.
And by the way, let's remember in his initial content cop, he
conveniently
Yeah, we've heard this whole spiel before, man. I don't know
why you just Does the audience still like this? They just need
to hear the recounting of how CPS was called every single time.
CPS, CPS, CPS. Skulls, skulls, skulls, skulls. Dude, why do you
think people have Discords with skulls as the avatar that have
CPS written across the forehead? Why the do you think it's because
you are obsessed with